hey what is that what is good whoa we're
back how you doing
I almost called you Phil so Phil sama is
it's Wednesday so josh is here I'm doing
good Bruce thank you mm-hmm
we were actually talking yesterday at a
meeting about our show that would be
starting in September yes and we were
thinking how great would it be if your
dad and my dad were like working
together like vice and Phil that would
be me and Josh Post at the same time I
don't feel to give Bruce a camera gosh
huh you're on the Wi-Fi huh you know
Wi-Fi had good stuff I hadn't actually
brought that up in the meeting talking
about his dad he goes he's the type of
guy that you get in the elevator with
him and he goes beyond the Wi-Fi you can
use the Wi-Fi yeah totally that guy man
all right we have we have a number of
fun stuff for the show today okay a
number of fun stuff a number we gave
Chris the disc assessment which is a
personality assessment to see what he's
really like
that'll be towards the end of the
podcast but we learned a lot about Chris
yeah when when they came to the office
you thought it was just gonna be a bunch
of corporate crap and then it turned out
to be a real indicator of what human
beings and what your personalities are
less so we dove in and we started asking
questions you know what kind of
personality is belichick have what about
Gruden's so we have that we have of
course whoa big offseason and apparently
your dad Phil Simms yes he can't come on
today no but we have a mascot battle so
we're gonna call oh good call him yes do
it who cares I don't know what he has
he's probably doing nothing I don't
really believe him when he tells me he's
busy cuz I don't know what he does this
time of the year suspend Phil kabisa
spent weeks shearling lettuce banded you
for a day yes certainly this is not
optional this is tree mandatory yeah I
know he's probably like doing bench
press right now and like I could do it I
got a workout we don't ask him for much
15 minutes a week I mean a ten minutes a
week and we're building his brand we're
making him cool speaking of brands yes
speaking of cool whoo I guys yes our
first t-shirt is now available
sym 70 shirt with all 70 quarterbacks
first names in the back ending with BL a
key ke Blake bortles is available now
we're gonna be putting it on Instagram
Twitter so yeah if you want the shirt
please it's getting hot and go to it bi
t dot ly / Sims 70 and that's what
you'll be able to buy it so if you're
not gonna be checking us out on Twitter
Instagram and you want the link bi t dot
ly / sim 70 it will take you to the
store it's available in white gray and
baby blue guys we really need to sell
some t-shirts so buy some shirts do we
there's a lot riding on this t-shirts in
the office today - yeah we got some
things floating around any more shirts I
saw one today there will be I'm just
gonna tell you oh there will be shirt
okay just more like we have some things
that we do here that we want on shirts
are just going to be great great
speaking of the Jaguars and Blake
bortles who the Jaguars have changed the
name of their stadium it is now T ia a
bank field or as Jaguars fans will call
it throw it away already
Bank field that's what it's gonna be t I
a bank state even heard of that Bank
what is that Bank I don't know I
remember I I one time was cover in
Kentucky and they played in the BBVA
Compass Bowl right and I did an entire
story just on what do you think the BBVA
Compass is and be like I have no idea it
was like a Spanish bank
yes but TIAA thrown away already Blake
great thanks thanks for you thank you
for telling me that was great so really
interesting the number one things that
we're interacting with right now in the
podcast in terms of social is whoa big
offseason yeah and people saying that
you're an idiot for your soccer take I'm
evil from Mexico I have people for it's
mainly from Germany right from England
right do you get so fired up yes and
because the World Cup starts next
Thursday we are gonna be bringing in BR
zone Dean Jones I brought him in for two
reasons one he's gonna crap on me this
is we are going to be having a
discussion right I somewhat agree
ballpark
and they are a football entity so it's
the same thing but I think that I kind
of agree with you yes but then I also
don't agree with you at all both sides
but I want someone to come in here I'm
ridiculous this is what I do yes okay I
mean I used to go around the locker room
ago I could beat many [ __ ] Oh up I go
yes I could beat many a back and you put
me in a fight with Manny Pacquiao I'm
winning cuz he weighs 140 weigh 90
pounds more as long as he doesn't get me
with that first punch and knock me out
he's in a world of crime what I need you
to do for Monday yeah have your points
the World Cup starts next Thursday it's
the perfect time okay have your big
points
maybe we'll treat it like court and I'll
tell Dean that we're gonna be the judge
yeah but I kind of wanted to be more of
an open to sky I know I don't
the reason I hate this is cuz I don't I
don't wanna you know I'm not trying to
upset the world yeah or just me like I'm
not trying to crap on soccer Dean Jones
though because this is a guy that lives
in English covers the sport at its
highest level yes and I'm sure he's
heard this before I've kind of told him
your thoughts on it so I'm excited to
get to it the other thing that would be
whoa big offseason yeah it is now become
a meme a picture of Chris Sims looking
down whoa big offseason vendrick can
kind of compiled a bunch Instagram one
that was my favorite he'll ask me today
their icon does it feel to be a meme and
I was like oh wow it's so special
do you even know what I saw yes you
gotta find a meme just what is a meme in
Chris Simms mind you know those stupid
videos people send me a you know Jordie
and crying meme that's what I think a
message that is repeated over and over a
great right now that message is whoa big
on my favorite Kendall shader
big Phil secretly wishes left go was his
son whoa that was my personal favorite
the part that kind of blew me away is I
got reached out to on Instagram to my
personal one by the Eagle is black and I
was like I don't know and the message
was hey Lefko I don't know if you
remember me but I was the big black
guy with the Eagles mask that was
trending on Twitter the day the Eagles
spanked the Vikings with foals do you
remember the video I just got on top of
a car and then it panned over and
there's a shirtless huge guy with an
eagle's knives you remember it was this
guy that's great he DN me and he said
after the Super Bowl a flood of people
came up to me asking for pictures and
the thing I thought in my head
Wow big offseason deals he goes yes I
know it's whoa but I was caught up in
the moment the Eagles the black eagle
he's a part of Sims and luf ghost like a
black eagle and the Chargers fan of the
draft super fans super fans they come to
the player podcast okay last thing I
want to ask before we actually start
this podcast and get serious here how
was the snoring received on Instagram
you know how couple memes about my wife
so I'm sitting there watching her scroll
and you're like already seen one oh I
get to what we had my son on there right
that was the same day yep so I don't
know how that was received him throwing
the football either way people were like
holy [ __ ] this is gonna be a lot of
people said better than bortles thrower
I'll say that but then the wife thing so
she had seen that she's to go and it's
so cute and then it was later on that
night and I was like you know watching
the Yankees game or whatever and she's
on the couch and I see her now and I see
you and me of the desk and I'm like oh
what's that one and I'm looking and it
says swipe Bob and I'm like oh no and
she's not gonna really listen to it but
she sent my I can see you're like she's
about to flip by it but she's going back
and then she looks at me and she goes
what is this what did you say and I was
like I don't know good I knew of course
and she finally turned up the volume and
listened and she was like wait that's me
and she started laughing
which was great started laughing then
she called me a jerk and some few other
things but it was good it was all good
so you're good yeah well this is shite
older listen if you want to keep buying
Yves Saint Laurent you got to listen and
deal with this so you survive snore
games I did snort games you know well
you know what it did though next night
no a little more
attention to the her snoring that's what
I wanted to accomplish do you mean what
did she do
we're realizing with my wife that when
she has two Lambs wife snores but she
eats too late really or unhealthy late
she's a extra snore now she snores a
little as is no matter what right but I
can deal with it and then when she has
like a late dinner inaudible about Sims
and it's gonna come to its head more in
the personality discuss us what Sims is
like you ate more it caused that I would
be like I'd wake up the next day be like
I don't know what it was but you really
snored a lot last night I would never
break it you're always going a to be I I
try yes I tried to be that's what
frustrates me because she'll tell me
things I think no you're wrong I've been
observing you have not you've been
sleeping shut up that's amazing alright
so that was it no thank you for these
snore up we survived we did have someone
suggest today that you should ask Florio
if he can be your divorce lawyer if need
be so I don't know what type of law mr.
florea Oprah I should make it a weekly
thing really just a snoring update yeah
we can do that a little bit we could
bring your wife friends just to salton
you just do Sims complains about his
wife and we can do a variety of topics I
think that's to be better too I think
they'll be great you're right okay I'll
do that we start getting a box at the
doorstep every day from somewhere I'm
gonna start filming that back here we go
I I played the clip for my girlfriend
right and she looked at me and she just
went Adam crazy like you're making my
relationship that's why we self Scout
yeah by the way Instagram one said we
should self scout we you were afraid you
missed somebody for safety and he said
asked him as if it was Eric Barry
Oh Barry would have been yes Barry was a
little bit out of my out of mind out of
sight out of mind because he was hurt
last year right but yeah he would be in
that conversation for sure yeah Barry is
a guy that honestly early in his career
I thought he was slightly overrated and
then later here in the last few years
I've got oh he's he's living up to the
billing now and he's one of those guys
too that I didn't really realize until I
met have been pretty bigger than he
looks in uniform he looks very he
wouldn't think he's a big guy but when
you do see him in person you go all
okay now I understand why it was a
top-15 pic and everybody took him over
her all Thomas cuz he's noticeably a
bigger yeah but Eric Barry I I feel like
his instincts have gotten so good yes
that now he's making plays that he just
wasn't making exactly right that was a
huge part of that much remember the job
he did in week one they wouldn't they
beat the Chiefs because of his ability
to cover our the Patriots because he
could cover ground cows not only that
when the Chiefs made their run two years
ago yes he was the one [ __ ] off a
two-point conversion against the Atlanta
Falcons he was the one picking off Cam
Newton and returning it to the house
he was the difference maker was and I
think that's why everyone was like uh
Ron Parker had a bad year no but when
you're used to playing with Eric bury
your responsibilities are different
you're more free so thank you Instagram
one for getting that in there I'm gonna
say this right now okay saying you're
going to be talking about Trump the
White House and the Philadelphia Eagles
I have decided that because this is not
a news show it is not a TV show it is a
podcast we could talk about it whatever
we want I'd like to have fun and then
have that conversation at the end if you
want to hear it it's towards the end
it'll be the last 15 20 minutes of the
show okay if you don't then turn it off
and don't send me anything because I'm
telling you at a time Wow so we get a
lot of people that get annoyed when we
talk about these know what at this point
you should know who you're listening to
yes
ie are the players podcast we stand for
the players you know what side were on
if you're choosing to consume it well
then you clearly want to hear it so
that's gonna be at the end okay I just I
want to give people an option I got you
know that in our landscape it makes
people feel a certain type away so heads
up it's at the end yeah we got to talk a
little bit at new sky Lanahan but it's
it's a little sad Dwight Clark passing
away at 61 mm-hmm
how about you a few times and I was
talking about him the last few days it's
not about me yeah why cuz you always
that you have a great saying about you
always say can you tell the story of the
NFL with this guy or without this guy
and Dwight Clark and the catch you can't
tell the story the NFL without that play
an incredible moment the catch NFC
Championship game against the Cowboys
are trailing 2721 Montana for a pass
by all stories and all recollections
everyone thought he was throwing it away
right it's funny I watch the clip now
and I know how it ends I've never gotten
that sentiment right but they always say
it look like he was throwing it away and
he jumped up so high I mean I I still
see people with rulers out there at
Candlestick going he got this high I
think the story that I read about Dwight
Clark that made me really understand
what kind of a person he was hmm
Dwight Clark on that picture yeah made
sure that Joe Montana got money but also
Everson walls the corner right of the
Cowboys the story is they had never met
each other and soon after that play
Dwight Clark runs out to Everson walls
at an event and goes you don't know me
but I want to get you money and
everything was like what are you talking
about he goes I'm getting offered tons
of money for this photo and I want you
to get a cut because you're in it too
and that's kind of who Dwight Clark
thanks to him Kyle Shanahan I saw an
interview where he told a lot of stories
I forgot Kyle was there with his dad
49ers right and has Kyle told you
stories about growing up around those
guys I mean a little bit I can't say
anything specifically to you know Dwight
Clark or anything like that but no I
mean that was certainly an extremely
important part of Kyle's life and his
upbringing his years at in San Francisco
living on the same street as bleacher
report founder Dave finocchio
right and that's crazy yeah I mean he
used to bring Dave Pinocchio's doorbell
to get an extra guy out for street
hockey and Dave told me that story so
that's just funny in itself but you know
that's where Mike made you know his name
for himself
94 49ers that offense what he did was
Steve Young was unprecedented at the
time what a that's such a dope team
staff young Mike Shannon's offense with
the one year of Deion Sanders yeah like
awesome awesome
Cowboys he was like you were just
incestual at that time they were player
they were they were and they were so I
mean that was pre salary cap and seat
pre free agency those so teams could
dominate the league 49ers they were
willing like DeBartolo and then the
family they were willing to spend more
money than other teams and so they got
really good players and I don't fault
them
for that but that's why DeBartolo is a
man what I love is I'm we have a lot of
people so there's three guys that I
think four guys that we get tweeted
about more than anybody else or
Instagram right Blake bortles Aaron
Rodgers Odell Beckham jr. and Kyle
Shanahan that to me is like our fearsome
foursome of the four people that talk to
us a lot right getting so many people
49ers fans being like this is the reason
we love Kyle and it's I mean it's him
talking about growing up around the
Niners as a kid yeah and that's what you
want as a fan as someone that
appreciates and understands your history
and tradition was there a quote or
anything he said that was talked about
how Dwight Clark and them would race him
and he'd have to run and they'd be in a
golf cart and like he'd be in the locker
room at that age and he's just growing
up around them yeah it's funny that he
grew up in the Niners locker room and
you grew up in the Giants locker right
now and that is probably so my dad was
the offensive coordinator to the Broncos
in 1986 on my dad won the Super Bowl
it's just weird to think we were in the
stadium that day together all those
little things that's why the football
beer world is so yeah small at times but
yeah I know it's extremely fascinating
the 49ers the team I hated the most
growing up I mean I hated the 49 I
looked at them and good my dad ones two
more Super Bowls if it's than the 49ers
if the Giants don't take my dad my dad
to this day he said it on the podcast
last week he thought he was gonna go to
the 49ers it could've been him so yeah
they made me cry more than they made me
cheer I'll say that I love it I think
it's quite Clarke that play
I don't believe Joe Montana was throwing
it out of balance right that was this is
that play became a staple in every
offense and the history of football from
going going for it and running behind
and they call a sprint right option
right it's the famous play every offense
in football has sprint right option in
and out because of that and then that's
particular play it was read left slot
sprint right option and you run out to
the right and really you're trying to
hit the quick guy into the flat right
there's two receivers trying to hit the
slot guy into the flat the bet the other
guy Dwight Clark what he basically does
is run like he runs like a deep coral in
the back of the endzone and he doesn't
get it originally he goes back along the
end line to the direction you see in the
cattle levels come so Montana is rolling
out he's going do I have the quick throw
okay
do I have Dwight Clark on the curl oh
it's not there let me buy time because
he's gonna come along the back line in
the end zone and I'm gonna throw it high
in the back and because it gets it great
if not no bounds right and that's
something that of course I didn't really
learn that part until I got to New
England New England it was the only team
Josh McDaniels where it was high in the
back low in the front that's third
that's the red zone their motto so if
you're throwing in the front low low
you'll see like Julian Edelman on the
ground catching it as he because
otherwise it's tipped up back in the end
zone it's Gronkowski or or Amendola at
the end of the AFC champion ville right
high in the ends right because oh if it
goes off his hands BAM it bounces into
the out-of-bounds of the crowd there's
no interception it's smart coaching that
other teams don't think about its little
details we're New England's ahead of the
curve that goes into the 6 and a half
step drop instead of the seven step
drive but just teaching quarterbacks and
now I'm curious when I watch Jacoby
percent and I watch Garoppolo too is
that gonna be ingrained it will be it
will go in the front high in the bag
will be because you start to recall it
it's a mullet for us exactly right and
those are the things like New England
and Denver I used to drive me crazy
because they would always cheat practice
how I talked about how you know you look
at the schedule and you go oh practice
only an hour and a half that's not bad
that I got 10 10 individual drills and
meanwhile there's a whole drill on lower
front yeah it'd be cool down period
practice is over and you think oh great
oh we got a cool-down period oh yeah
yeah Sims lined up with the five all the
receivers line all below the back line
we're gonna just throw balls high in the
back of the end zone and you go damn
this wasn't on the schedule but the
cooldown was drinking wrong right maybe
a light stretch middle of the field when
I go to the gym and I'm working out with
a trainer I use the water fountain as
like that's like that's my eight seconds
to get away to like get away from him
and just be like I need I need another
break yeah
do you get that like like it that like
can you be like I need a water break
coach like doesn't happen at football
practice yeah a little training camp
there's so many people around to keep
you hydrated now because they don't want
people cramping you don't squirt water
in your face it's like a constant it's
like you get done with a rep and
you're truly walking back to talk coach
like somebody's there to like you even
have to hold the bottle yourself they
just smell sporty or even if you're
standing on the map they had the water
cows in the back right the water cows
with all those you just spritz sprite in
your mouth to reflect what happens the
Korey stringer everyone was gonna be
high faculty right my question was more
is there any way to get away for 10
seconds oh there any way to like kind of
stubble you me like or like if you like
move your shoulder they get back with
you know like not necessarily yes no way
to take a break no it's it's you're
right there's really no way no
especially a quarterback it's it's
pretty hard to get that but your break
is your stretch period like you're
stretching here we go to start practice
get your mind right or have your few
laughs in I mean I like I've told you
before I think I've told us before I've
never been more nervous in my life than
my first full day to a day practice with
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers I mean I can
still remember it see a plane in the day
I'm sweating like a mother effer and I'm
just it's pouring off me and I'm
hyperventilating and I'm talking to
myself going damn I mean I played
against Oklahoma last year in the year
before it was two verse three and one
verse two and I'm more nervous about
practice today and then that's where you
have your chance to kind of get your
[ __ ] straight I forgot there was one
other thing that I posted so I went back
and I found the video of Bryan
Westbrook's play against the Tampa Bay
Bucs and it's literate really incredible
third down and six fifty seconds left
throws a dump off four yards he makes
six people face and then algorithms
everybody out to the touchdown good the
thing that caught a lot of people's
attention could you found this game
broadcast yeah oh yeah there it is
me and Luke McCown and they were saying
look how skinny I look how many pieces
of gum that you have in your mat so
everyone say everything Chris is on his
Pete Carril you're just sitting there
like oh just chomping away yes I don't I
don't I don't even you eat a shitload of
gum now that's what I mean I don't put
one piece in if I'm gonna have gum it's
like we're going five or six deep he's
can you imagine you're like I got a
piece of gum and he's like oh you're
back and it's like I had six pieces
that's the problem with the NFL to the
and this sideline they have big drawers
of gum bazooka this is a bobble bubble
no but you're just like if you're not
playing I mean I'm stuffing my pockets
with it I'm just throwing them in all
game long I'll just pieces losing a
little juice let me throw another bubble
type but you know what was just I feel
like it was either bazooka if the team
had it but more time double bubble was
the bubble double bubble gum divas he
ever played with who are like I need
bazooka enough with a double bubble guys
had their preferences but I felt like
that always came down to the juicy
fruits spearmint or double mint got it
that looks like I'm a juicy fruit guy
that's all I do just give me those
yellow ones over there and you know
throw them a few packs those are great
yeah I remember I mean I my dad used to
like trident I was like that's the best
one I ever saw I got to go out in the
Yankee Stadium as a little kid and catch
batting practice in the outfield because
of Willie Randolph son right yeah and
the gum and candy they had in the dugout
oh my gosh I mean I was in a sugary
little shoe was the best oh just just
never-ending supply of it I think the
craziest thing about big league too is
they tried to make it usable for
children to get them used to John there
yeah alright so it is time for whoa
big offs easy and before I get going we
were talking in our in a show meeting
about kind of taking whoa big offseason
to the next level
and I don't know if you guys are
subscribed to the sims and left code
newsletter we got a few hundred people
that are and it's a cool place where
it's a collection of of what we're gonna
have the link for the shirts there any
new news that we have and also stuff but
the guy that kind of puts it all
together is is max wheeler we call him
wheels and he wrote something for me to
take whoa big offseason to the next
level so he listened to our whoa big
offseason on Monday a lot of wheels and
and here's some some more big offseason
today
what if I told you that one man's legs
could shock a nation that thunderous
thighs and giant calves would make
crowds roar and that legs Benedict isn't
just a breakfast has a good one what if
I told you that a man could fly and leap
tall defenders in a single bound
what if I told you that size does matter
Sims and Lefko presents a whoa big
offseason film say quads coming to a
practice field near you
August 2018 so I think what we're gonna
do now no like we're talking about
decorating our pot area sake wands legs
need to be in here so just a picture of
sake one squash the golf picture Gaga or
the other one I saw earlier this week
where is it got the ball in practice I
think the one that like obj tweeted at
that one picture I mean he looks like
he's got an extra head on his leg on one
of the quad muscles that nobody was
saying that Tony Dorsett had famously
big legs and ass he did he had some
great legs and ass I don't know if they
were quite this thick because he's a
small guy quad
do you think say Quan has bigger legs
than Jim Brown yes Jim Brown oh look
because Jim's were big for that day and
age but this is a different day Brown
made lacrosse change the rules and as he
would stick the stick between his pecs
yes and you could hit him and nothing
what happened yes I think he's a
naturally bigger man I don't think he's
quite as muscular dense as take one man
all you gotta do is look at say Kwan
power clean four hundred whatever pounds
I mean that's disgusting it's incredible
I mean that's insane to be able to take
that off the floor get underneath it and
then stand up with it but the real point
is that in an NFL locker room where legs
and ass are a plenty about s and this
guy is carved himself out as mr. legs
and ass already and tells you that even
than their guys are going holy you are
saying that's some whoa biggest ones
Pickens no so I think we also do this
he's gonna listen to us break down whoa
big offseason and he might come back
with a you know a little 3430 treatment
on the
ones that are really good way to go he
said them a homes one got his brain
thinking I gotta make it alright so
let's get to the new ones for today this
is a quick one whoa big offseason Baker
Mayfield saw Josh Gordon in quote I've
never seen anybody like him that's like
the Josh Gordon response that's every
offseason someone says that about is
that surprising to you that's what I
said when I first saw him in person me I
don't to me this isn't news now whoa big
offseason if Baker was like Josh Gordon
and I've seen we and Oklahoma yeah of
course he's never seen anybody like that
no ask him the question what miles
Garrett he's gonna say the same thing no
even the whole John Sheppard was really
big right like Julio Jones and the AJ
greens of the world who are really
impressive in person
they don't stack up to what Josh Gordon
looks like in person it's pretty
shocking at first it really is you just
soar like gosh damn that's a big guy
think about that Browns team so you have
miles Garrett on defense
you got Josh Gordon on offense even
though we're not the biggest fans of him
as a football player do bill peppers in
the way he's built like David and Joe ku
yeah like they have a lot of studs they
do a manual on buzz a stud
I mean Christian Kirksey they just got
Michael Kendricks I mean he's a stud I'm
Jamie Collins Aramis said that they're
gonna win 8 games next year I think
they're gonna be I think they're gonna
be anywhere in that 4 to 8 range it's
gonna be how they handle some
fourth-quarter situational football fad
and I want to see the offensive play
calling yeah because if Hugh's really
giving it up I have a lot more faith
that Todd will do in Todd right all
right the other one though from the
Browns this is such a good whoa big
offseason Hugh Jackson intends on
withholding stripes atop the helmets
until guys have made the 53-man roster
whoa quote there's a certain way that
the Cleveland Browns have to play and
we're going to quote earn our stripes
whoa big offseason the Browns are now a
high school football team does this
motivate an NFL player it's like a cool
thing when it's all set you're not
motivated by it I thought it Lyons right
now we're practicing with our lives
right first thing is like in minds
stupid wait the Browns have a stripe on
their helmet right down the middle right
yeah they do for sure now pull the
picture don't say oh you're thinking
it's a complete are they adding the
stripe this year that's all I'm trying
to say I guess like I yeah no they do
have a stripe I'm stupid you're right
they do have the speck yes totally I'm a
controversy my question is though as a
player yeah do you see that gimmick
[ __ ] in this yeah yes you do
you don't really care as a whole it's
just another little thing to you know
again change the culture make it a
little more more special that when you
do make the team to go oh okay it's
official now here's our team doesn't
really mean a lot to a lot of the guys
no it's not a big deal um it's uh it's a
whoa big offseason it's exactly right I
mean it's yeah there was teams that I
was a part of I want to feel like we did
that one year at Texas where you had to
like earn your Longhorns right little
things Nebraska's obsessed with that
earning your black shirt I don't get it
like not like that cool thing about
Nebraska is you could leave Camden want
like endemic ensues the only guy with a
black shirt they're like damn like when
I see a college game and there's teams
with like millions of decals I think you
guys need to step up what you think a
good players yeah I get that
except for Ohio State I'm usually the
those teams lately I'm like damn they're
really good they all make good there's
like 12 rows on that team every year all
right whoa
unleash the Negi Nagy was asked about
his offense and how is it gonna be
different than the Chiefs and he said
it's gonna be different in some regards
but really the identity is gonna be the
same but this is where it turned into a
whoa coach Reid always said he had 51
percent of the say so ultimately he had
final say now I have that there are
plays I like that coach Reid didn't like
and now those plays are in
sure abyss keys run in the super-secret
Navy plays they they have you know
coaches as we've talked about a million
tests can be stuck in their ways with
certain things and Andy Reid might have
some few schemes where he goes we only
run this scheme when we get this
coverage right and Matt Nagy might be
gone why because this scheme works
against this coverage - why are we
canceling out this great play and coach
Andy Reid together you know this is the
way we did in Green Bay in 1993 when I
was in Brett Favre we're not gonna
change yeah you know they have their
certain ways about them I can you know I
remember instances in my life where
coaches had these conversations with
people but yeah I'm sure Matt Nagy he's
gonna have a few things that we didn't
see and a few concepts that he probably
was wanted to be aggressive with and
Andy was like I don't feel comfortable
with it I love when this is in business
like I love wouldn't bleacher report
hire somebody that was overqualified for
their last job and wasn't able to do all
of their ideas because then when they
can come to a place like bleacher report
they could blossom same thing with
coaches I love the Kyle's the mcveigh's
the McDaniels the Nagy's that are under
traditional coaches yes and they're
waiting to blossom and like when you
read the stories of they had a whole
playbook of things they've been saving
waiting to use like you used to talk
about Kyle and I don't know if I'm
allowed to say the coach's name but
don't say it but go ahead just keep
going he wasn't he would never be
allowed to run certain plays and Kyle
cut that in a certain part of his
notebook and was like I can't wait to
run right right there's there's a number
of like I can think of X coach friends
who had these little arguments or
whatever it may be they might've been
the quarterback coach at the time and go
no this plays good and then they got to
become the offensive coordinator and
they did it we all get old right we all
become uncool right learn that at
governor's yeah this weekend
I'm no longer governor Terry's all right
I looked around that was like you need
to be more mature stop drinking so much
and I was like what is going on to me
someone like Gruden yeah Gruden was the
young kid Gruden was this super young
offensive coordinator i became a coach
but I so eventually
he's going to look at his young people
and go this doesn't work right was he
like that or was he open to any he was
open to it have you showed results he
was open to it so even though Goethe
might have been like well we only run
this play against his coverage if he
started to notice on film that other
teams are running this same play against
another coverage ago you know yeah that
doesn't make sense okay let's we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna change our
outlook on this play and we get two of
these either this coverage or this
coverage right we'll run the pipe we dog
then we'll change Gruden to me feels
like the perennial young guy well he's
always wanting to be young at heart he
never wants to get old I would agree
with that statement
all right last whoa big offseason wow
this is so big
Carson Wentz our good friend Chris
Mortensen dropped a monster whoa
one quote people inside the Eagles were
somewhat skeptical I'm hearing that
whence is not just ahead of schedule
he's way ahead of schedule he
participated in seven on seven
he threw a ball 60 yards last week
effortlessly if I saw that I look up in
the air and say wow the way he was
throwing the bomb pregame of the Super
Bowl and one leg I was like gosh damn
that's better than half the league right
there his legs are fast he's stronger
he's not just head of schedule
he is shockingly ahead of schedule whoa
big Aussie that is big is it yeah I mean
it is to be able to say that I mean hey
okay yeh Torres ACL look he's getting
more reps than Andrew Luck is right now
I mean that's that's big it is I never
know if if they're trying to motivate
the guy if they're trying to make the
fan base feel better I still think this
is you don't get rid of Nick Foles
because now in case whence can't go
we're trying to repeat get him in there
for the first few weeks of the year
great but you don't think that this
could maybe be over height like you know
I think this is I think more I don't
think Mordred Mort is the kind of guy
that I mean he might have heard it from
a player or two but he got it confirmed
with coaches or the owner the GM it's
somebody really important the head coach
whatever it is and I think that that
would be a thing that coaches would tell
them more because not they're not this
is not a propaganda thing they're truly
amazed they're like damn this this
damn kid I'll tell you what when Adrian
Peterson right he tore his ACL for bite
he just been here and he's been here for
24/7 and here he is he's you know out
doing all what we thought he could do
and then of course what's the number one
thing that's driving him I mean Dave he
doesn't want Nick Falls to start week
one that's all he's waking up about
every day he's going GunStar week one
gotta get to know they've gotta get to
the facility got to start rehab got to
do what I got to do can let that happen
that's their guarantee it's the first
thought and his brain as he rolls over
to get out of bed in the morning the
number one thing is Nick Falls can't let
him start week one I gotta be the guy
don't want to have to deal with this
[ __ ] for my career random out of love go
field that I just thought about this
one's really on a left go for ya
hurting his leg was the best thing
that's ever gonna happen to Carson Wentz
for the Eagles and here's why okay there
is no pressure now on him as the
quarterback of the Eagles we have our
Super Bowl ring that's true you're not
starving we are net and in even if he
plays well we're okay number two I mean
I get about the long part of his career
I am playing reckless and maybe having
something happen later on another good
it happens when he's super young his
body is able to hear heal faster and
it's actually better that happens now
and it could change the way he plays in
the future and making him have more
longevity agreed and also three with him
the leader of the team being so hyper
motivated to get back the thing that you
worry about as a fan of a Super Bowl
winner is complacency with him in their
fighting tooth and nail it's impossible
to be complacent because the leader is
hungrier than anybody on the team all
great points and he's still in his own
mind wants to prove
something's wrong with Nick Foles but
the cool thing is is most Eagles fans
will tell you we would have won that
game with Carson Wentz yeah they do it
seems like they have a great grasp on
reality there's no fans about the
situation I kind of think that Carson
Wentz busted up his leg could be the
best thing that's ever happened the
Eagles face it could be III you're all
those points were spot on I'm the only
way I would push back just from being in
the mental aspect of all prior to where
I look at whence and just go this is the
one
that could be bad about it is that he
puts too much pressure on himself now
because he's gonna I gotta be able to
prove I can win a Super Bowl that's
what's happening so that's what I mean
it can become that that would be the
only negative I could look at that but
other than that I think everything else
you said is pretty spot-on and I would
think that they're really true for the
most part I I have never been more
impressed with a quarterback I mean this
is a guy that held a softball game and
raised over $800,000 for charity
launches a food truck giving away food
ahead like he's exhausting he's too good
this is like him and JJ Watt I look at
those guys sometimes just go I don't get
how they do it Russell Wilson's in there
Tia exactly right guys I could never
ever ever comprehend living that life
but I'm super happy that I get to
experience watching yeah it's amazing I
would be more like the Brady type guy
right like you don't put Brady in the
same belt break no because like they're
exhausting themselves along these lines
all the time Brady just feels like one
or two great events all year but I think
he's so focused on his job and he's so
probably paranoid about it all the time
it's exhausting doing Carson Wentz
Russell Wilson JJ Watt win a game where
they're incredible and then the next day
they're at a hospital right and you're
like and Tom Brady is like I need my
rest right here in my mind I'm not
trying to say anything myself with this
one blue berry exactly he's in a minute
my try I hope nobody's trying to
interpret us the wrong way because he's
amazing especially the little football
thing he does it Harvard Stadium every
year for the I think it's cancer it's a
great cause yeah just us things to bite
his head for charity that's great but
these guys are not non-stop it's
everyday I'm amazed by it the energy the
ability to always do it I mean I know I
would go crazy as an athlete because I
know I would also be always just be like
you know is this gonna make me tired is
this gonna make me worse at practice and
they continue to show that it affects
their performance that nothing at all
it's like they're being propelled by a
higher power something like that maybe
they are
I think the Saint that was the rare well
big offseason that actually didn't
deserve to be mocked you started with
the Carson Wentz tough and Chris was
like no this is the way that I look at
whoa big offseason is I am presenting
something that fulfills all the
qualities of lobokoff season right it
looks too good to be true like I didn't
include this one Kenny gala day is quote
looking like a veteran like whoa because
that is his second year to me that
didn't make the cut but that is a whoa
big offseason where people are just like
oh let's overreact to this he was like
whoa big training camp to last year if
you remember calories all right so now
just amazing quotes I have three really
great quotes we call it Phil Phil Simms
I mean yeah let's call him yes sure
let's call he'll say damn let's see if
he actually answered what longer that's
all right conversation well we had a big
Phil said he can't do it today yeah but
you know he doesn't get any time off it
says again this is not oh da work we've
been in we've been in mid season for
Buri there's no there's no offseason of
podcasting I know I mean there's never a
day off the podcast you calling it what
are you doing over there I'm texting
people you're not paying attention all
right well we'll just wait for the ring
in our ears here there it is
all right so this could be the boy I
have to yell during the voicemail right
so I don't hear his number since the
people know there's a three in his
number somewhere I can't believe he's
bowing out I know he's got nothing to do
either he's been like the most fakest
non busy busy guy you've ever seen in
your life they're ready to yell should
we should we call back with a star six
seven
[Applause]
school Bilson's
at the tone please record your message
when you've finished recording you may
hang up or press one for more options
hey big [ __ ] what's up man it is
Wednesday and podcast yet didn't want to
come on thanks for supporting your son
show appreciate that just so you know
that there is a $5,000 fine for not
showing up this is not OTA this is
mandatory training camp and I don't know
we were gonna do a 49er versus a Steeler
today yeah but you're not hearing the
same I got nothing I hope you're playing
ping pong
yes that's what he's doing he's probably
down the basic processing yes thank you
well hopefully you show up to the ping
pong match because you didn't show up
today
thanks thanks love you a lot powershot
see ya hang up on that guy I hang up on
that game damn I know big Phil oh oh
what sucks is I had a question and
actually I'm gonna ask you what see me
yeah I'll see if I can answer and if not
we'll get Phil the next time ok this was
from Instagram 1 we heard him earlier
Instagram big podcast for Instagram on
he said he had a story that has high
school football coach used to tell and
that all the guys in the team didn't
believe I'm gonna used to tell it so
here's the story once he told our team
that his college team that cut the high
school coach played for Tennessee Martin
and they played against big fill in the
Morehead State Eagles and he said that
Phil couldn't handle their defense
throwing multiple interceptions and
getting sacked many times sounds like he
would end the story with quote we hit
him so much that he left the game on a
stretcher after that day Phil Simms
never wanted to come back to Martin
Tennessee do you think that sounds true
I mean I mean getting sacked them
throwing interceptions in Morehead State
I mean I know there were some years they
were they weren't good yeah they're like
really like three and eight maybe his
last year or something like okay means
something so yeah he got his butt
whooped by a lot of football team so all
right so like that for the next jazz
back you can ask him about that I doubt
the stretcher thing is real I don't
think so I think you know he's at the
College Keys Reggie White I think he's
okay at Tennessee Martin that's what I
thought yeah but but yeah you never know
I don't know his Morehead State teams I
mean he talked
and they weren't very good it's amazing
how many 1000 always think about yeah
you're the number seven pick in the
draft you went to some crappy college
and you still got picked the number
seven how did you do that
it's high school he wasn't any good high
school teams either if you think about
it now phil simms comes out in the draft
now Morehead State three and eight
interceptions out the wazoo no
completion percentage he all he does is
throw a deep all the carson wentz Joe
Flacco which is funny when how heroes
John Chandler Thomas school and they
were asking about Carson Wentz he said
Carson Wentz didn't work for any of our
models the only comparison that we had
in our database was maybe Phil Simms
yeah he said that yeah he goes because
it's one double-a right and how do you
even like compare those metrics right
but yeah it's hard I know that's why
that's when it comes down to you have to
be able to just evaluate the player the
player by himself
and have a good eye for the things that
you need at that position would you say
that of Phil Simms was like Carson Wentz
was he starting free food trucks and
going around to hospitals definitely not
he's probably too scared of Bill to do
that
like that's that's he would never I mean
dad was always charitable a check would
be a Bill Parcells upset volunteering he
was scared I think to do anything too
much in the public or the headlines he
didn't want over ever overdo it because
then I think he was afraid bill would
use that against them in some some shape
or fashion thing you know was amazing
after we had the conversation last week
we talked about you know I think with my
dad like where he was talking about like
build wash came to Morehead State right
and yes Oh beautiful a nice throw he
went on a story later that night just
telling me about other teams and how
many teams I it's actually when I was in
a tell him to say today because he
talked about all these stories and what
jumped out to me about the story is how
much more hands-on the coaches were at
that time and he looked he stopped when
I said and he goes you know you're right
they were I mean it was the coaches
would catch balls for me during workouts
he tells a story of Joe Gibbs coming
down and they're just having a catch
together and then Joe Gibbs just goes
just move back a few yards start
throwing me some real ones and my dad
says he throw him like 15 balls and Joe
Gibbs said I'm
good I've seen enough and that was it
and it's just amazing right because
that's the way Rd know like can you talk
over the bill wash but I do think there
was more of a hands-on experience of
that day and age than Myers now my mind
immediately went to the Bell check video
with the NC State lineman but you know
we don't really see videos like that
that's why everyone was so surprised
when it came out look at belleau check
in there he's working out with the guys
talking to him it's funny too because
now we've turned into analytics and
studying film and we have to have
experts and gurus and all that stuff and
I think it's like a lot of companies
that started 40 years ago well how did
you know that you you wanted to do this
it's like just gut feeling you got my
job and some people like the Joe Gibbs
and the Landry's and and they're right
Lombardi's they just had it and there
was no how can we make this a system it
was we have Joe Gibbs right we don't
know how this my whole life I know this
is the main image in my mind of coaches
during the offseason now is Pete Carroll
in a press box at the combine just like
kick back you guys process the
information right and give me yeah right
all right so my favorite quotes I have
three really really good ones we're
gonna start off actually with Vernon
Davis talking about Alex Smith and scars
he says you could tell by an individual
scars right based on their scars that's
how they're able to be successful alex
has been through so much so many scars
so many offensive coordinators being
treated from San Francisco a lot of
scars and this is my favorite part the
reason he's successful is not by
accident it's supposed to be it's
inevitable so Vernon Davis is looking at
Alex Smith and going he has been through
so much he went on to say the Alex Smith
looks better now than he ever has
remember this is Vernon Davis that
played with Alex Smith in San Francisco
I love that now he is seeing him think
about this from Vernon Davis he is
seeing Alex Smith before and now he is
feeling compelled to talk to us about
scars he must Alex Smith must have a
look in his eye that is so different now
than young Alex Smith that Vernon Davis
is going this
man has been through a lot yeah like
it's almost like Mad Max where like you
look at me more like what have you been
through yeah Alec Smith must look older
or weathered or tired that's his boy
remember remember Vernon Davis was not
happy when they went to Kaepernick
remember I do remember right so because
he's Alec Smith and Vernon were they had
a connection and that was kind of like
his safe target like oh I'm in trouble
I'm gonna always go to Vernon so there's
obviously - Crabtree a lot exactly and
then of course he could run so that was
meant and less balls to Vernon and there
seemed like there was I don't know Frank
friction but you know there's definitely
a relationship there yeah Alex Smith has
been slighted a few times
certainly IIIi won't dispute that but I
would also but the notion this is where
I would dispute he got a free six years
of the NFL without getting any scars I
mean I don't know how you want to put it
but he didn't do crap his first six
years yes and he got to hang around
because he was the first pick of the
draft right right so I guess what I'm
saying not everyone gets that chance
exactly right and you just got to take
it both ways it's never perfect there's
only been like 12 guys in the history of
the sport that have had perfect careers
I mean trying to think who are some
other guys that started off and we were
like bus boss boss boss boss and then
they were able to turn it around oh gosh
there's a I have these guys in my head
I'm gonna choke under the pressure right
now yeah he is I know but it's my
argument with first-round picks all the
time that's my problem with first-round
picks like like that let's just say the
kid from Alabama they're running back
Derrick Henry I know the other one
Richardson is out of the league yes but
you got to play for nine different teams
it was like men the first three all
thought he sucked and got him out of
there in like three months but he was
the number three picked and we had a
great grade on him so we're gonna bring
him in this offseason who Eichenberg
exactly right it was like I'll take a
[ __ ] on right like what right yeah
you're right
Arian Foster though like you better make
it right away undrafted forget there's
this extreme pressure there all right
here's another quote that I really
really like Melvin Ingram pulling a Bill
Withers
so Melvin Ingram did a Super Bowl
prediction happens ever
off-season someone says they're gonna
win the Super Bowls Malik Jackson last
year with us honestly
next guest we have on probably won't be
Gronk will be someone else we're gonna
get someone and go hey you're gonna win
the Super Bowl they're gonna go yes
we're gonna go awesome let's put that on
the quote card put all the Instagram
it's gonna spoon but my favorite part is
he was obsessed with the word grind so I
think it's gonna be crazy this Super
Bowl we're going to win we're ready
we're grinding we're just gonna keep
grinding we're going to grind grind
grind grind grind grind grind no matter
what keep grinding no matter what we've
got to bring a Super Bowl not since Bill
Withers have I heard someone repeat it
so if you know ain't no sunshine
I've known this for a long time Bill
Withers says I know 26 times because
when I was younger I loved that song and
even grind it so for me Melvin Ingram is
coming here going we're gonna grind
grind grind crying crying crying I loved
the Chargers I love tennis it's Anthony
Lynn that's it was talking right there
that's Anthony Lynn it's not Melvin
Gorham's I said did someone put that in
his brain Melvin it's Anthony Lynn
that's the kind of guy he is like we go
back to the drug Bart we're gonna work
harder we're gonna be better we're gonna
do this better it's he's a true grinder
Manthan elin there's no shortcuts
there's no BS type-c big-time same time
see on the disc assessment but yes yeah
I'm with you men are the Chargers
overhyped
properly hyped or not getting enough
hype no I think they're properly hyped I
think they're the team like what are
they being hyped up just the general
consists everybody gonna watch out -
watch out team ALC right shout team IV
NFL I think that's true I mean I think
you and I felt that way about them at
the end of the season last year we kept
we were kind of rooting for them to get
in the playoffs because we said they
could be a team that could make things
hard on New England we wanted to see
good football so we like that and damn
they got Pouncy back they got the kids
laying there not Pouncy not I mean
Pouncy they got the kid lamb who was the
first friend who got hurt last year you
even get to play you got to Durham when
James I know they lost hunter Henry but
you know Jason Barret wasn't out there
last year you got to remember that
they're gonna have the linebacker
healthy for the entire year yes kid from
Miami
yeah Parenthood yes way to go Josh
oh hey CeCe guys Ryan oh yeah my last
favorite quote comes from Joe wit the
Packers defensive defensive passing game
coordinator everyone latched on to the
quote where he said we want to remove
doubt out of the equation that was the
headline that I saw everywhere so that
our guys could be more instinctual yeah
but when you Dovan to his quote he had a
line that's great he says he wants his
guys to make plays want to remove the
doubt you quote you cannot tell the
difference between a confused player and
a coward
because they both move slowly love them
that's a great move use player and a
coward
yeah so he was saying we need them to
know the plays because right now they
look like cowards but they're not
cowards they're just confused
great great quote it really is you're
right there's no difference at that
point of the stage you're not sure
you're good you know is he and sure of
himself or is he just afraid to go over
the middle you know whatever it may be
but yes you can't you can't show your
true physical ability unless you're in a
comfortable state of mind right I mean I
think it's goes for anything right I
mean whether it's your work Josh or your
Adam I mean when you're we're here at
bleacher report we're comfortable we can
let our true colors shine through it's
the same thing in sport it's it's so
especially a wide receiver wide
receivers can be mentally locked to
where you could go to him this guy runs
for four when I just go over the field
and we throw together with each other
and I tell him what route to run but
then we get into practice and you know
he's jogging because he's always
thinking he just can't let it go and
that's what happens uh-oh big offseason
is coming here whoa big offseason I have
said this before I just got an alert
from the BRM e added clue okay no so
tomorrow night Thursday night was his
football I'm going to Philadelphia to
interview Malcolm Jenkins and I'm
extremely excited for it they want to
talk about the Super Bowl but obviously
everything that's happening right now
and we're gonna get to the anthem thing
the the infant policy of the White House
is a 49er I have said this for a long
time I want to save this for the end
I'll just say right now I have said Oh
what would you rather them do
you talk about it in your pressors and I
said no we know when do you ever see
videos of press conferences or
interviews at their lockers it doesn't
happen I said that someone should not
talk at their presser Malcolm Jenkins
did not speak at his locker he just held
up signs about charitable things that
his teammates are doing things like you
aren't listening talking about Colin
Kaepernick he's only holding up signs
you need to think about ways to break
the media that are changes that we are
not used to that's how things spread
Malcolm Jenkins is doing that right now
we're gonna have more on on the anthem
in a little bit but man Malcolm Jenkins
have been alert I have a feeling I'm
gonna ask this to Malcolm tomorrow if
he's planning on running for office when
he's done he could do it because I I
think that he might be a guy that ends
up really going far in politics I agree
he's doing ride-alongs he's like like
with police officers to better
understand it like like you only doing
that if you're gonna run for governor
he's got it all yeah yeah he really does
um all right you want to have a mascot
bell yeah everyone take a deep breath I
don't even have great arguments on this
one so I don't even know where I'm going
no we're gonna let Josh kind of weigh in
at the end yeah I'd like you to kind of
run it I don't get to make the decision
I think we're gonna go to the fans okay
and we're gonna go on Twitter difficult
of Josh from there
so Josh would you like to start off with
Sims or myself ah man I'll start off
with I'll start off with Sims today okay
so you are going to be a 49er well
listen I'm not afraid let's just say
that right off the bat I mean traveling
across the country to improve my
family's wealth improve my state of life
no problem deserts mountains rivers
whatever it may be we we're determined
group of people the 49er I mean we know
what we want there's nothing gonna stop
us not the plague or chlorine or
anything else we're gonna get to where
we need to go I don't know if that was
the proper way to say that word
it's called exactly that whenever
someone I was looking for all right but
men are we a determined tough stamina
based group that has our eyes on big
prizes unlike the steel worker who's
just willing to take the offer and just
bang things for a living just go well
yes sir whatever you say bang bang bang
we're worried about our own personal
wealth and greatness and we're thinkers
and then we're not a elective steel
worker we're not afraid to do the dirty
work either but we just want to be
rewarded more we're not cogs in the
system where they just tell us they
punch in and punch out no we're a little
bit more innovative that way we are
looking for gold we're digging for gold
we have a sharper blunt instrument his
instruments kind of blunt to him if it
comes down to the side beam it's a steel
beam mine's a steel pick with a real
sharp thing and just if it sticks in the
head it's over he's done okay now you
feel any remorse for mining the earth
and not respecting the earth no I don't
know right now because I'm just worried
about beating the steel there okay
honorable Josh left go fans I'd like you
just let's just think about the
characters we have here okay we have a
gold chasing Californian and a suit
covered Pittsburgh Ensor well they
weren't California so they got there but
sure 49ers ran for greed they couldn't
hang Steelers stayed and built 49ers dug
for money Steelers dug for their
community Steelers helped invent
football outside the mill so let's just
say that they speak to our hearts he
mentions that the 49ers use a pick axe
and the Steelers use a steel beam here's
what I know Josh and everyone out there
as the fight goes on the pickaxe gets
duller those swings get slower the steel
beam still enormous I think it was
Aristotle that once said fast guys get
slower big guys don't get smaller that
was Socrates and that was SimCity's oh
it was Sims
oh so you said that yes well then I rest
my case
but then there's you know there's the
also the key you know this is where the
other thing goes is just outside
we're smarter outside the box thinkers
to where that's where I think the fight
really goes bad for you guys it's funny
because actually I think was actually
the philosopher Joe Witt that said we
need to stop thinking because you know
cowardice and confusion looks the same
so they can think all they want we have
a steel beam coming at your skull do you
just wanna do we even need to go to the
vote why why would you just leave us why
do you think you've won decide at what
point do you think you made that was
just crushing know your facial reactions
and you've you're feeling like an L he's
already because I'm laughing don't worry
two steel beams that's an L it's not a
ship it to you alright what's next in
this podcast what do you think what do
you think wins that fight I don't know
to be honest when Phil is on the phone
it's intense it's angry people get
pissed off you guys were both a little
uh a little reserved today I know I
don't really don't think anyone won that
yeah I will be curious to see what the
fans thing absolute disrespect that I
get during mascot battles do not talk
about a fight I think the 49ers just you
know it's a little more smart of a
creative guy just came in here and I
gave me dance limbs he gameplay as a
system yeah next week yeah alright keep
telling me that we have to iTunes
comments that I'm really excited to
share after this one other conversation
before we get to the 49ers though just
how it's like a similar thing and they
have it both have great franchises i
they're similar like people like they
profession yeah but this was a question
from Matthew Cole web he is a die-hard
Raiders fan born in Florida and he asks
what do we think about people that route
really hard for teams that are not their
hometown teams are we okay with that I
would prefer it not be that way but I
understand the world's not perfect and I
can take it from personal example myself
you know I'm if I was gonna be self
scout myself as a little child I like
the Chicago Bills
Michael Jordan over the New York nets or
the Chicago bills coming up tonight on
TNT is the Chicago Bills in the New York
nets
I said Knicks and nets Knicks and nets
but yes that was a team where I was
growing up where it had such a
polarizing figure and I'm you know I'm
eight years old in 1988 and Michael
Jordan scored 37 points a game so that
jumped out to me and then I jumped on
the bandwagon yes but I at some point
jumped off at when Michael Jordan ended
so yes I would say I would prefer you to
be a fan of your hometown team but
there's also just examples of like oh
maybe your dad was from that place and
he made you watch these games growing up
or whatever so I mean I understand it I
feel I won't let my kids not do that I
feel this way whoever you root for and
just be consistent yeah if you had six
years old saw the Raiders and you really
went and everyone was giving you [ __ ]
but your whole life you've been a
Raiders fan I don't care well I speak
consistent just don't be like ooh you
know what now that I live in Florida and
the Jaguars are good again I think I'm
gonna go back yeah yeah that's annoying
the most annoying fan to me is this fan
I think you're gonna agree with me right
is is LeBron James who is his favorite
baseball team yankees berra football
Cowboys right those those are the ones
that drive me crazy oh your favorite
basketball team's Golden State your
favorite football team's New England and
then your favorite baseball team is the
Yankees whoa you live on that one huh
and then that's the band that every now
and then I just go I understand that if
you're like 13 or below and that's your
team's but that fans can annoy me it
really does say more about your parents
than it does you
yeah like I refuse to let Phillip mean
he is gonna be a Yankee soon he is going
to be a Giants fan yeah and then he's
got a pick between the Knicks and the
nets right now he's saying the knick
because he likes porzingis
oh yeah like Nick Sixers will be an
issue if I have a child eight amazing
football team all right so - speaking of
personalities yeah we got our first
guest so let's welcome him in Sims I'd
like to introduce the first guest ever
in the podcast room
congratulations what's
Galia link Turner
he came what was a few months ago his
last fall when I say and I was very
skeptical yes there was this thing
called a disc assessment and it was
gonna tell you how to be a better
coworker employee person and explain to
you really who you are and it's not a
test and why would you come to the lab
and why because I do not believe that
answering random questions is going to
exceed sure you get this all the time
yeah but when I finished and I think
everybody a bleacher report finished
yeah we looked at each other and went
holy crap was that accurate and I'm sure
you get that all the time too but the
other question I got all the time Sims
was what do you think Sims is and I
mentioned I test tell people today Sims
is taking a disc assessment and they go
oh my gosh I need to know so let's first
go all right so wait this is fine disc
assessments do what I would like you to
explain to us what it is what it does
for businesses in the workplace whatever
it goes go ahead sure so again Brian
Blake from Turner people development
thanks for having me guys hey man the
disc assessment is not a test and it's
an assessment that looks at workplace
behavior and how that behavior
influenced how how you communicate with
people how you come across to people and
what to look for so that when you're
communicating and interacting with
people you can understand their style
and sort of communicate and interact in
a way that's conducive to their stock
share so there's some really good
capability building and it's gotten very
popular not only a bleacher wood across
Turner and Shore organization
everybody's asking for it and so and and
I think the main reason why is it it's
accurate and it's fairly easy to do yes
so and that simplicity really makes it
appealing do you feel like the Wonderlic
it wasn't the Wonderlic it felt more
like the psychological test that teams
give you though when did I give you
though Oh either at the combine or the
Senior Bowl or on a you know a private
visit to the facility but like you said
this was easier when you only have two
what was it 25 28 questions write it do
it in 15 20 min right
once the NFL teams give you at times are
250 questions 150 and you feel like
you're answering a lot of these same
things like multiple times to where it
was annoying doing that this one was
actually like okay this is moving along
pretty quickly and it was making me
think a little I want to do this because
I I just didn't realize NFL teams were
doing this I feel like a quarterback and
a wide receiver they should take this
and feel how to better communicate with
each other a quarterback in an offensive
line that's what I would like to know I
mean do you think there is true
correlation to like sports being able to
use this absolutely right absolutely
because at the end of the day yeah
everyone has different communication
styles ever you got introvert or
extrovert you got everybody's got
different medication styles so the
better you can understand it the better
communicator you'll be the better you'll
wipe out a lot of unnecessary nonsense
talk or whatever so this was mine
I was deemed a persuader the four
categories D is what discipline hominins
dominance eye is influenced yep s is
steadfast steadiness and C
conscientiousness okay so and you were
an influencer or a persuader very so let
me explain that so I gave you guys what
we call the classical behavior profile
patterns okay and so what this this does
is explains how your collection of of
where you came out on the disc profile
and the behaviors that come with that
fall into certain patterns and so this
document explains what your pattern is
so my favorite verse waiter yes and it
said Adam may use his verbal abilities
to paint vivid word pictures which can
make the abstract concrete bring people
together or finalize an agreement and I
like put the paper down and I was like
what that's what I picture you doing
actually walking around the offense
office influencing people with a talk
and opening your big mouth I told Brian
before you came in I said here's what's
weird about Chris Chris has someone that
will come in and you can't spell HR you
can't spell curse without HR like you
come in and you yell something but then
you'll also want to be by yourself and
like watching film yes
and then you know you're a little bit
you could be a little bit reckless and
be like I'm gonna say what I want but I
also need to eat the same food and I
know I know so I didn't know where you
were gonna fall why this charge so let
me say something
here's amazing thing about discs is that
yes your your indexing higher in certain
quadrants than others right but the
premise of disc is that everybody on the
earth has elements of all of these and
you just have tendencies in certain
areas and there's a million things
variables that can contribute to that it
the role you're in you know the
environment you work in the people you
work with it's all types of things yep
so so it's not unusual that you'd think
well I wouldn't really apply that person
well actually it does because everyone's
got it it's just a matter of where they
fall and where the tendencies tend to be
so what is a typical high D person like
very driven very results-oriented driven
by success I mean that that's everything
to a high D okay likes to be in charge
right you know things of that nature how
about a high highs relationship-driven
you'll find it a lot of salespeople or
highs I'm a high I people who are good
spokespeople people who are you know are
really excited about being I don't know
I was gonna say popular not popular but
but like to be well-liked just you know
those types of things what about a high
s high s so these are your steady people
these are people who like harmony they
like to know what's going on it's not
that they can't deal with change but
they really really gravitate toward
stability right so they can deal with
change but they might a little bit more
time than then maybe some of the other
groups and then a high C Pisces are very
data oriented very analytical very
logical huh
so my wife's never taken it but I'd say
she's probably Heidi and I see how do
you not give I mean compatibility you
got your wife I you know I let her make
the call
snoring I hear that and I go that all of
those are Sims like that was my issue
yeah like like definitely a high D but I
also think you're an eye and then s I'm
like routine based your mr. rout am i no
see analytical like I just hear all of
them right yeah all right I'm ready
you want to take a look now yeah sure
let's do it have you seen my results are
my dream lies I want it Brian to come in
and go I've never seen anything like
this before and what you said I really
haven't seen some of these things before
right yeah yeah so I not yeah not this
shakeout right right not with the actual
where you came out this I've seen right
what's coming out in the behavioral
review I found to be fascinating oh I
want you to read that part
sure so I'll take no please my life is
already I wear it on my shoulder test it
was 28 questions yeah let's see if it
sounds like service so just as a as the
reason why I keep harping on it's not a
test is because at the end of the day
tests are about right and wrong correct
right and this has nothing to do it
right or wrong good bad better or better
better or worse none of that stuff it
just is right and that's the hardest
part of people to grasp I have to keep
reminding people about this so just
before we start into this so but my
normal dia SC results I'm what would you
say we're the D I'm hiiii right this one
by Heidi and then your low s and even
lower C okay that doesn't mean you don't
have SNC we're just not indexing high in
those areas right God how does he
compare to me so let's see you're high
so you're both high I your eye is almost
off the charts your D Adam is closer to
the midpoint whereas a little bit more Z
is higher
you're both low in the other areas but
your lowest is s and Chris's law as to
see interesting you know what that tells
me what there's no there's no surprise
me why you guys we work together success
because that diversity of capabilities
complement each other
well oh gosh so this this is usually
when we do this it's with intact teams
and what you may remember Adam we did
the thing where we had everybody stand
right boom and we saw how it how how
much diversity there was and how that
actually made those teams better yeah
because all these capabilities were
complementary it's just it's just
awesome okay all right so so I'm not
there's a lot I'm not gonna be a little
bit but I'm gonna call out some things
that really jumped out it okay Chris
tends to be very direct
daring forceful enthusiastic may also be
very charming and sociable can they be
quick and thought in action he may enjoy
matching his wits and skills against
others about doesn't sound good Ashley I
don't know what what else really jumped
out at me
Joe generally charming in his contacts
with others he may occasionally cause
them to experience a conflicting feeling
of being drawn to him and yet somehow
being distanced at the same time wow
that's deep that would agree I would
agree with that probably cuz I can be
opinionated I can let it be known and it
might not be what everybody wants to
hear at times here's another one that
jumped out at me while he sometimes may
inspire fear and others and may override
their decisions
Christopher tends to be generally
well-liked by his coworkers
that's amazing you're pulling that off
buddy that's what that's major explain
that again so well here is here this may
be true because he tends to use his
considerable verbal skills to persuade
others rather than demand from them
whenever possible got you crazy other
things jumped out at me Christopher
naturally may be comfortable with
interpersonal aggression in fact he may
enjoy competitive and and and and
antagonist and antagonistic situation
but agree he may welcome the challenge
of a win-lose situation
the last thing self-starter chrisser may
get up early to get a head starting
today's activities he may start
activities without any prodding or
direction from others his energy may
continue to be high throughout the day
that's crazy crazy 28 questions yes
funny these guys these are psychologists
have put this together and I've
got to think their absolute geniuses yes
I mean it's fascinating it's just
fascinating to hear because I was I was
interested to see where it all went and
you know I just feel like there's you
know again there was a few questions in
there too where I wonder how much it
would have been dictated where there was
some where I was like oh if I chose the
other answer right but there was because
there was a few examples of you know
okay you have to choose the one that you
think you're the most like at work and
the least like it weren't right and
there was a few where I was like oh I'm
kind of like all of these but which one
it was most of right right so it's very
interesting psychology there and I went
back and forth like self evaluating
myself as I was doing it going which one
truly portrays what I am at work
the at work thing is critical right
because a lot of people some people are
same at work as they are at home some
people are very different at work as
they're at home and so to be to be to
make it a true workplace evaluation
that's why they sit in that evaluation
assessment that's why they say think
about it from how you behave at work yes
it's just crazy how spot-on about like
you know the confrontation thing or the
welcoming the challenge is like how you
can get that from that test wild and
know that is amazing I'm surprised more
sports teams don't use this do you
really think that most quarterbacks are
gonna end up in your categories and then
I'm curious other positions right like
offensive lineman like how about you
describe a position to Brian and Brian
tells you a third dirs or say yeah so
describe offensive lineman okay sure
quarterbacks I mean our quarterbacks are
your type-a personalities right somewhat
perfectionist and do like routine base
right like I'm gonna get up in the
morning I'm gonna have my eggs and my
bacon and then I'm gonna go watch film
and then I'm gonna meet with coach and
I'm gonna watch a more film and that
would be your cut your quarterback who's
you know worried about every little
detail in the world making sure he knows
details of others right so in case it
goes ah we break the huddle and there's
you know some dumb receivers like I
don't remember that play you can tell
them right away on the fly
quarterbacks I think are generally
pretty quick on their feet thinking
while
yes and this is where I think it would
be interesting with quarterbacks some
quarterbacks don't give a damn what the
rest of their [ __ ] team thinks about
them and then there's their eye low and
then there's other quarterbacks who
would be very worried about does the
team like me are they around me give an
example of each of those a quarterback
that doesn't care in a quarterback that
cares oh okay let's see I think like if
you think about like I think a Peyton
Manning back in the day in his prime he
was a guy that I don't think really
cared about what his team thought he was
gonna say and do whatever he had maybe
yeah Brady would be in the same thing
too yes there are low eyes there are
lower eyes right and probably higher
sees right and the reason why I say that
is you think about you know I think I
would say generally quarterbacks are
Heidi's yes yes because everything is
about results and for quarterback has
constantly shoved in their face I get
that yeah I respect it right I could see
where some quarterbacks would be hi eyes
and I could see where some quarterbacks
would be high-seas because you have to
dig into the details yes right and so
you know quarterbacks who I don't know
the one two are always fluid always
consisted in your throwing motion maybe
they don't maybe they're high C's
because they're staying on top of it or
maybe they're not because they don't
have to because they've got that down
the guys who are constantly having to
tinker or look at you know what you know
my arm tool or whatever maybe those guys
have to be high C's to make sure they're
on top of the details yeah you know I
think what do you think Odell Beckham
would be receivers let's just do
receivers in general superstar receivers
right very diva incredible self
confidence right like I can do anything
what I'm odo Beck I can be LeBron James
at a dunk contest probably just off the
charts self confidence everything with
DEET also you know details can be iffy
like not horrible but not you're not
gonna go oh he's you know a rocket
scientist over there and he's all over
every detail you know also I would say
very emotional position very emotional
it's high I super high yeah that's what
the kind of guys they are what would
they be low in
like where it's a great question I feel
like it's funny either CRS yeah about
essa stability like those guys don't
come across as like the diva ones will
come across is super stable to me so I'm
gonna guess no lo s I think your odds
right there too because the receivers
are - they're so physically gifted -
they're not always worried about all the
little details of the world right where
I can go to the club til one o'clock in
the morning and still come out and run
for three tomorrow it doesn't matter
Randy Moss one of the greatest driver
seats of all time right that guy from
what I from what I remember watching
just hear from analysts cuz I'm a nut
about sports sure is that he didn't
always run the best route no same thing
with Dez Bryant they'd always run the
Bret now or Dez Bryant go up and get the
ball yeah Andy Moss always came down
with the ball but he's not always
running the precise route maybe wouldn't
be the Patriots yeah - but you know it's
the attitude of don't just just throw it
there I'll get it I'll be there don't
worry about it now
with Sims as Heidi I feel like my chart
might be the wide receiver chart and
Sims is the quarterback show like mine
is the super high with no s which we're
talking about as a wide receiver right
and Sims is the higher D with a little
bit more s right what do you think yeah
I see it my my assessment is very
similar to yours yeah right so it's just
like the algebra you said where you
might words and be like quarterbacks are
masters at that not to say I'm worth the
damn as a quarterback or anything like
that but damn I did grow up in the
household of it and listen around a lot
my life you're right so but quarterbacks
are the masters of like being able to
verbally abuse a guy on your team but
also making them feel better about it as
you're doing it like man you didn't
block [ __ ] last week left go you
couldn't block him off the right deck I
got bruises all over my body but somehow
being able to portray that into like
it's alright we're gonna get them next
week and it'll be fine who gives a damn
so I could seek I can see as a result of
that I see quarterbacks
very high eyes right there one day yeah
I should ship to be strong yes
who's your best friend well everybody in
the orphans but the old line especially
could the old line especially yes how
about the old line you've often
described them as cattle right say that
they are there they they do not spend
their model cattle they're grazers right
they they will stand off on the side of
the yard and not work or do anything and
just talk about all these interesting
subjects and have great intellect
thoughts and all that but don't really
want to work until the strength coach
comes over and goes hey would you here's
the poker I'm going to stick it in your
ass so you'll finally go out in a squat
like we were supposed to instead of all
you hurting together in the corner here
trying to manipulate a way not to work
out save their money they saved them
they're fiercely loyal fiercely loyal I
would say this with the quarterbacks the
smartest guys on the football team very
practical like annoyingly practical at
times that's a high ass high s's so we
may be low ID practicality yes those are
things that s's value right absolutely
yeah high s's and highs typically get
along no sure mmm yeah which ones is
there are there two that typically don't
get along so if you look at it on us oh
I brought this with you guys can see it
if you look at it on on a piece of paper
here right and you will see that DS and
C's go together
dn eyes go together C and SS go together
I and SS go together gotcha
don't typically see is D and s above the
quadrant hmm or I and C above the
quadrant happens I think I've only seen
it once right and I think it was I and C
but the behaviors that that come with
those things tend not to flow together
as easily yes and that's why you just
don't see it yeah so yeah they would be
asses so if you had if you had a
dominant quarterback that did not care
about anybody else then they could clash
with there s is a lot it's not because
that quarterback to me sounds like a D
and the C and C and the S is tend to go
together gosh yeah right because you can
have the D in the C together he's
conscientious
he's got that too which is very I can
see that as well and then you've also
talked about corner backs and defensive
linemen are the cockiest guys on the
team yeah let's do D lineman first our D
lineman are okay if old linemen were
cows D lineman are your castrated bulls
okay right they're pissed off as hell
right they don't they're angry they just
want to be let loose and I don't want to
be over and you know overindulge with
too many details and thought process
here I just like what do you say coach I
go get the quarterback I go get the ball
okay great and I'm ready to fight and be
scrappy and really work like that i D
that's a high D yes okay yeah now think
about it Oh defensive linemen definitely
have to be results oriented yes they get
paid on sacks and hits and no doubt
about it right
so they're so they so they're definitely
result oriented that sort of dominant
you know got a run you over you're right
you are you third of my dominant people
in the locker room yeah what the hell is
Belichick he's definitely a D he's
definitely a sit
you think he's a seat no I don't know
about an S DN C D and C an you know what
his C might be higher because he's so
detailed and thinking about everything
we think I'm a lot more efficient we did
hear about emotions yeah you know all
that controversy lately there's no fun
to play for the brands and his response
well we're about winning yeah so he's a
DNC and I would say hi see do you want
to work for people like that
or are they really hard to work for I
dominate follower yeah that could be
that could be that could be challenging
Jon Gruden Jon Gruden loud emotional yes
not detailed and smart but not too
detailed to the point of like a
Belichick or maybe some of the other
coaches there's trade for the Hackenberg
kid he did yes not afraid to take
chances that's good influence you I'm
gonna say D&I I'm trying to figure out
yeah I would say he's a big-time
influencer because he'd be the type of
guy he'd sell his plays by like
plays of Jerry Rice like I'm gonna
influence you to show you this play
works really well here's Joe Montana and
Jerry Rice in 88 he strikes me as
someone that the relationships are
important to him yes so yeah I'm gonna
say hi I was the ID yeah that's my
that's my I think you're right his I
think the relationships are important
doing he it is important for John that
especially the core guys on his team
like him I always felt that way about
him that he cared a little bit more than
maybe some of the other coaches I was
around right if they got along together
the right way so with what we learned
today
how can Sims and I work better together
now that we know what our charts are
well the interesting thing about you
guys is you're both high eyes hmm right
that that was the highest for both of
you now Adam yours was a little higher
and then your D Chris is higher than
interesting thing is that you both
indexed high on the same things and low
on the same thing just slight variation
right so to me I think if you guys are
both relationship oriented it's already
working
yeah right just keep doing what you're
doing because it you've got a natural
flow to what you're doing the podcasts
are awesome obviously and so just keep
doing what you're doing man
keep communicating Patrick what were you
talking to my ear do you member what you
were he was a very high C so the guy
that we work with the most is a very
high shine what's he in charge he's
don't he's Bill Belichick of Bleacher
yes exactly right
conjugates oh gosh I didn't drive let me
do that oh I got a meeting at 3:30
here's their Google map how to get there
and your calendars there at all that's
him
do you want to do in a pitch anything
just you got a Twitter or something you
want to get to know you know the only
thing I want to pitch is that you know
I'm really grateful that you guys
allowed us to allow me to be with you
today cold my internal people
development we're trying to do great
things here for the whole Turner family
and so just really appreciate you guys
having us thanks obviously I'm really I
think this could be to me if I was a
head coach of a football team right
this is I don't know necessarily if you
know of course you would learn things
about your players doing it this way
totally but I think even more would be
learning your staff all right that's
right let's go totally see this with
position coach that's right we're need
to know how like okay I'm Bill Belichick
how can I better communicate with my
receiver coach who is a recluse and
doesn't talk as well whatever it may be
but still has tons of value to him
exactly right smart as hell but I just
got to get get it out of them whatever
it may be what do I need to do what's
going to appeal to that person right
right absolutely yeah this is cool
I enjoyed it thank you brother thank you
guys thanks for shooting ok that was
awesome you actually learned a lot from
Brian yeah I'm excited to go back and
read this whole report because some of
the things you said I think my wife's
gonna get more of a kick out of reading
this than anything it was really like I
really went in I was like walking around
the office before I took it I was like
this is [ __ ] and then like I took it
and I was like this is insanely accurate
i I just like I told Josh before we
started I would be interested in like
the handful of questions there was maybe
out of the 28 questions there was like
four or five were I really was undecided
like man which one do I pick here it was
like do you what do you like more
communicating with people in the office
getting your work done right weird
things that are not right and I just
wonder if I Cho if I chose a different
answer on those three or four that I
wasn't sure about how much it would have
swayed my assessment so let me set up
what happened I'm sure everyone's very
well aware with the White House and with
the Eagles and where we are today but I
kind of want to set the stage and then
Sims I want you to go okay so we've
known this has been on the table for a
long time even leading up to the Super
Bowl both teams were asked if you win
would you accept the invitation Chris
long didn't go last year he wasn't gonna
go this year apparently and according to
all reports early on the Eagles sent
back that about 70 people would be
attending when it they found out that as
few fewer than 10 people were planning
on going to the attendance for the
ceremony one of them being the mascot
the White House rescinded their
invitation so that they were disinvited
and instead we're going to hold
a ceremony to celebrate America I mean
we're gonna play songs and all that
stuff it ends up there's one report that
Nick Foles was going to be the only
player that was going yeah it was gonna
be a celebration of America here is the
part that a lot of people made it it
became an issue in the White House
statement quote they the Eagles disagree
with their president because he insists
that they proudly stand for the national
anthem hand on heart in honor of the
great men and women of our country for
everyone and I'm sure you all know none
of the Eagles kneeled the entire season
so the White House said they're there
they're not coming because they want to
kneel and the Eagles are going not only
do we not want to kneel
we didn't kneel the entire year right it
became even more complex when Fox News
began airing clips pictures and and
making it seem as though the Eagles were
kneeling but in those pictures it was
actually prayer or pregame prayer or
postgame prayer and so actually taking
photos of prayer and making it seem like
they were kneeling very it seemed a
shock panda no no yes now at the event
again I'm just giving you all the
information the reports I've collected
it all right here apparently two
visitors knelt during the playing of the
national anthem at this celebration of
America this was also being tried to say
is maybe they didn't feel well those
people came out and said no we were in
fact kneeling another thing that that
happened somewhat a heckler yelled stop
hiding behind the Armed Services in the
national anthem let's hear it for the
Eagles and then also the other big story
was apparently Trump doesn't know the
words of God Bless America or the
national anthem that came out there have
been a number of people that have come
out Malcolm Jenkins put out an
incredible statement online explaining
how you know all of the things that them
and their colleagues have done working
with police departments elected
officials community advocates Chris long
and how he donated his entire season
zone
salary the Philadelphia Eagles and how
they have not knelt at all
but what he did say is we do all this
stuff we help out because we love our
country in our communities regardless of
race or socioeconomic status we deserve
to be treated equally we are fighting
for racial and equality none of what we
are doing is trying to be anti America
anti-flag anti military but you're
painting that picture of us yes so
that's sort of all the information of
what's happened Donald Trump did come
out and say oh no these were Eagles fans
that were there a Philadelphia reporter
spoke to about six random people
throughout the crowd said can you name
an Eagles quarterback they couldn't
making it seem like they were plants the
only other story that I thought was
related to all this as another story
came out that Trump told White House
officials they should punish the NFL in
terms of a tax plan yeah and that's the
story about why Trump was sort of
attacking the NFL as a whole and how he
was going to attacks them surprise
surprise right in there why he's never
gonna stop attacking the NFL they didn't
let him in the club twice they told him
he's not rich enough so he's never gonna
stop this is we know that he is a little
petty that way your reaction to all of
the events that have unfurled with the
Eagles and the White House and and you
know just kind of your take on what has
okay because people are excited to hear
European okay all right well the first
thing I would say is this if I was in
defend Donald Trump in one issue I would
say this I think any president would
have canceled this if they found out
that less than 10 people were coming
right so I'm not necessarily mad at him
for canceling it right I don't I even
think it is whether it's George Bush
Barack Obama Bill Clinton Ronald Reagan
I think if they were holding a ceremony
for a football team and they said men
there's one players yeah one Peyer
showing up they're gonna cancel that
event so I'm not necessarily gonna sit
here and bag on Donald Trump for that
but it's the language after that that
bothers me okay
and that's where I don't even know
really where to begin this conversation
all I can say is that I am extremely
discouraged by the lack of leadership
coming out of the White House on a daily
basis that's what truly bothers me as an
American
I have lived a privileged life growing
up in northern New Jersey Silverspoon
atmosphere yes I'm willing to say that
and I know that but I also know being
around football in the country and
whatever else that most people have not
been nearly as fortunate to me and
people of color have had to deal with a
lot of social and justices whether it's
watching the Milwaukee Bucks player be
tasered a few weeks ago for parking in
the wrong parking spot or the Starbucks
people being kicked out or how about
yesterday footage came out of a guy in a
stairwell I didn't beat beating the crap
and knocked unconscious and it didn't
get reported until they found the
footage the same day let alone all the
Trump tried to turn this around right
the Eagles were not being paid right so
let alone those things on a personal
level and without being political I'm
willing to vote the Republican or
Democrat I vote for the person okay so I
don't care I voted for George Bush twice
if anybody else wants to sit out there
and judge me because at the time I
thought he was the right guy to run our
country okay so again I'm not against
that but I'm against the human of Donald
Trump right now and again like I said
the lack of leadership and the divisive
this as we all know and really just
having showing no compassion really in
my mind to anybody other than his base
and I think that's what bothers me and I
think when I really break it down to
this is where my final piece comes and
we're the football podcast and we were
the players podcast yes and I was gonna
say I'm very critical of players and
coaches okay
and if I said the White House was the
33rd team in the NFL right and Donald
Trump's the head coach okay I mean if we
held Donald Trump to the same standards
that we held NFL head coaches he would
have been fired five times by now he's
had six offensive coordinators in his
organization he's had five defensive
coordinators he's had a fire his head
press guy he there is so many he's got
guys on his coaching staff that are
being accused of cheating here being
accused of cheating there so we were
gonna be
he is critical of Donald Trump the way
he runs his organization as we are of
Mike McCarthy in the way he runs the
Packers then I think it's a total
embarrassment from that standpoint out
of the fact that the guy has shown
tended some racial tendencies there's no
way to really back away from that in my
eye whether it goes back to when I was
growing up and the Central Park five
where there was a murder in New York
City and five black kids were arrested
and accused and they said they were
innocent from the start and Donald Trump
was buying ads in the newspaper saying
they should be executed and then DNA
came out science which doesn't seem to
want to be acknowledged by the
thirty-third team in the NFL the White
House that DNA came out that these kids
were totally innocent and they figured
out who was never apologized nothing
whether it goes back to sons of [ __ ]
kneeling and calling people holding
Confederate flags and Nazi flags find
people I just find them disturbing at a
human level
I'm not against all Donald Trump's
policies there are some things I like
but to me that's where it bothers me I
have young kids growing up and he is
setting a horrible example of leadership
on a daily basis and I think that's
where I stand there's so much more I
could say but for right now that's all I
can get out of mine so for me I think
what's interesting is if you told me
like like you said you don't blame
Donald Trump for canceling right mm-hmm
here's what he did that no one else did
not only is he gonna cancel
I'm publicly disinviting you and you
don't honor the flag and now I'm making
it a celebration to give you reasons
that aren't even and I'm gonna sing a
song and we're gonna do it in spite of
it that's what he did that they wouldn't
do yeah but here's the deal if you said
let go you're not gonna believe this
Donald Trump took another shot at the
players and blamed it on the flag my
response would be whoa big offseason
yeah it's like that's expected but what
happens is he's in might what I'm seeing
is people are still being amazed that
he's saying and doing crazy things
instead of looking at what they should
be amazed at which is the reaction
you know that I am someone that drooly
looks at stoic principles and I try to
implore them in my life one of them
being I have no control on other
people's actions I only have control of
my reaction to their actions and what is
happening right now in the NFL is the
best reaction to Donald Trump in all the
world politics government education
health athletics all of them the Eagles
are the best reaction to Trump in the
world and I have never been more proud
that the team that I root for forget
they won the Super Bowl how they've
handled themselves during his time has
been so admirable yesterday a Giants fan
came up to me and a Washington fan came
up to me and you know what both of them
said yeah I hate your team but I'm
jealous of you right now right for them
they couldn't morally respect their team
as much as they could respect my team
it's I had a Steeler I'm rooting for the
Eagles but what they did I could only
hope that I dream about right they have
become your mayor let me just say I want
your mayor to be my Mary Jim Kenny cut
the frogs blind right but it's really
funny as I went back and I found an
episode 137 before week 8 what did I
call the Philadelphia Eagles America's
Team I went through the the Chris Long
donating a salary Malcolm Jenkins doing
rila lungs the kicker that was pulled up
out of nowhere that hit a 61 yard field
goal John Durham Bo's being on America's
Got Talent being cut finding a heart
disease and being okay the quarterback
Carson Wentz that donates to the food
programs the coach Doug Peterson that
was a high school gym teacher four to
five years ago and now just won the
Super Bowl an owner that was willing to
go out there in an owner's meeting and
said that the president was deplorable
they are America's team they are that
team it's no longer debatable ice and I
said it's really funny I have the clip
we can't I said if you want to get on
the win swaggin right now this is the
team of destiny and then they went on to
win the Super Bowl
yeah but I think from my perspective
what I'm trying to
here is the problem about talking about
Trump is you end up start talking about
politics and nationality and it becomes
topics that you're not going to be able
to change people's opinion and you just
begin to yell at each other right that's
why I wanted to do this at the end but
we stand for one thing here and that's
the players podcast and the reason that
we care so much about the players is
there is no other sport that treats
their players like this none know when
they get into an argument with an
overbearing president that calls their
players sons of [ __ ] and if they
don't stand should be deported they go
you're right we'll have them protest
somewhere else so they don't support the
players ideas doesn't happen in the NBA
doesn't happen a major league baseball
doesn't happen in NHL oh it's the only
sport where the contracts aren't
guaranteed so the money isn't even
secured oh and by the way you know that
whole banging your head thing we're
gonna hide scientific studies for
decades so that you'll continue to hurt
yourselves the NFL treats their players
like garbage why there's our there's a
lot of me that loves that Trump's doing
this to the owners they treat the
players like crap yeah and as the
players podcast this is not politics
yeah someone needs to say hello you're
treating these people awful and they're
the ones making the money we're so
willing to fight for the college
basketball player because look at all
the money's being brought in what about
these professional athletes that are
bringing in ten times the amount of
money on a yearly basis and they're
being killed in front of us for no
respect and getting no support
I know so my thing is this isn't
politics Trump has said I can I can get
the American fanbase the American
populace to support me by saying I stand
for the flag I don't know if I have
sweaty oh yeah you do damn well I stand
for the flag right and they don't yet
another person that's willing to insult
NFL players and marginalize we need
five times that's fine he doesn't do
ride-alongs like malcolm yeah he called
our first african-american president not
a citizen of the country that's right
yeah he can go
I could shoot George Comey in the head
and you can't do anything but see that's
to me the battle that's being fought
there but these underlying messages all
the time at first black president you're
not even a citizen of our country I show
you no respect I'm president I can shoot
James Comey and there's nothing you can
do back
I can't even obstruct justice I am king
Trump yeah so from that again the
personal aspect of it and again I'll say
this too I'm I'm Silverspoon North
Jersey I know some of the people that
know Eric trump and the the younger
Trump's and the people that I know know
them let me just tell you I don't like
him they ain't good people they're
racist and when they told me they were
friends of the Trump I was like shocker
and that's the way they are as a whole
and I just yeah it's just it's just
disappointing on a human level more than
anything that's where I'm not I don't
care you wouldn't treat anybody like
that I'm not trying to compare the
president to any other presidents I'm
not trying to say that his policy I'm
not trying to say that you should care
about the anthem less I'm saying this
are you a human do you care about other
humans do you see how these humans are
being treated these athletes that go out
there and you might think they're
spoiled but look at all of the examples
on this Philadelphia Eagles team see all
the sacrifices they are making and
realize that no one on this team is
spoiled but they are so representative
of everything we want in this country so
my thing is this the president is
treating this team like crap the players
they need to get together they need to
figure this out but I left yesterday as
everyone got more dismayed very proud
yeah because the Philadelphia Eagles
have no control over what's being done
to them but the way that they are
reacting I couldn't even fathom that
this was possible and I'm so proud that
they're my team I don't think football
that sport
I think football represents America more
than any other sport it's the true
workman's sport get your hands dirty
work harder you'll be better you know I
know they think all professional
athletes are spoiled yeah certainly to a
degree but damn let me just tell you
this out there for anybody who wants to
know
ninety-eight percent of professional
athletes especially football players
whoo they came from the opposite of a
spoiled upbringing
I mean upbringing is where again I'd
like to bring some of my you know white
friends that I grew up with in northern
New Jersey who had lots of luxury things
and go let me just show you what the
other side lives like at times because I
know you think you know and you watched
Boyz in the hood but you don't know you
have to see it I was that same person
that wants to so I'm not judging when I
got to go to experiences with friends
and go to the hood or go to their
grandma's house who raised them or
whatever those are i opening experiences
there you go man this was rough
they had no favours in life how the hell
do they even make it out of here that's
what I used a lot of times what left
with my friends where they grew up I was
just like it's amazing they made it this
incredible it's amazing how were they
not shot killed how did they get out of
school they had no leadership nobody to
teach them the right thing but somehow
they did it on a daily basis so that
would be my defense of the spoiled
athlete thing as well one other thing
this is off the anthem this is an out of
left go field submitted by ten Jay
Johnson he deemed me and he said hey
when's the collective bargaining
agreement I said it's supposed to be
like 2021 so yeah yeah he said he thinks
one of the main reasons Vince McMahon is
waiting until 2020 yeah to bring back
the XFL is he knows the player lockouts
gonna be there and he can get the bottom
part of the NFL and maybe steal some
steam so to attend Jay Johnson I think
you nailed it yeah like there is going
to be a great decision by the XFL
especially now that they got Oliver Luck
running it who a lot of people it just
gives them a little bit more credibility
but the fact that they get to feast on a
weakness in the NFL that we've been
talking about coming now for years could
be really interesting it could be they
certainly could steal
yes that bottom 10 15% of the NFL to
where teams are going damn you know
we're missing our backup linebacker he's
starting in the XFL or whatever it may
be those are the guys they're gonna
actually about we actually miss games
and 20 that's what I mean if there's the
threat of not having money again NFL
players most of them are making less
than a million dollars yes so they can't
just afford to sit back for a year or
year and a half and make no money and if
I'm the XFL I'm running it like I would
WWE where let's say it's week five but
let's say Jarvis Landry really wants to
play you're going on a team and we're
running you out the tunnel like it's WWE
Raw and it's like what does that drive
us Landry's now in the Orlando Rays
right you know I mean like that's how I
would run it just make it an ongoing
thing who cares about the teams but the
NFL better gets smart because with every
area every action there is a reaction
Donald Trump's not going to be in office
forever but your actions kind of helping
him when he's there we'll never be lost
on all of these people the owners we're
gonna know what side you're on Goodell
we know what side you're on and the
players it will impact in the future
yeah
so here are two iTunes comments I want
to read this one is from West four seven
eight quick shout-out to you guys my
name is sergeant Garnett west of combat
logistics battalion 31 31st Marine
Expeditionary Unit stationed at Camp
Hansen Okinawa Japan so I read that and
I went holy [ __ ] we're either gonna get
reamed out for us I was just thinking I
was gonna damn I'm here yo he's gonna
yell at me being stationed in Japan
makes it hard to keep up with sports
being 13 hours ahead you guys keep it
100 with all topics and current events
especially sticking up for Lamar Jackson
after the no-name gutless coward
reporters attended to slamming Sims a
love ko keep it out with the hard work
for others to emulate you guys are the
bar Semper fine thanks man that's a lie
this is how I feel if you listen to this
podcast and you are like I am a staunch
stand i I can't separate them saying
that it's about
the anthem and then what they're
actually trying to fight for then like I
don't get why you're still listening
like that's just my thing like everyone
says you should you should make your
your content good for everybody
you know who we are yeah you know who we
stand I can't help I'm sorry yeah like I
can't help it I mean right now that's
just what I I just I want to be I want
to keep it I don't want to say I'm gonna
keep it a hundred because if I'm trying
to be a broadcaster that's like well
maybe they do have a point then I'm just
everything that I hate in the media
right so you're just shitty we're just
gonna keep it real because you had
enough fake [ __ ] on all the
other TV networks that are afraid that
you know where they stand yeah I stand
for humans and the people that [ __ ] with
humans I don't mess with them they're
not my kind of human yep and end all
right last one this is great we're gonna
end it here amazing comment along my
Memorial Day review and the commenter is
meat hen so I don't know if it's
supposed to be a five-star review left
it on Memorial Day may have had a few
beers in them I hope so I kind of want
what's a good patriotic song left guy I
mean there's a million of them don't
don't pick something with commercial
music please what is this alright just
read the review left go let me saying
god Bless America
ok I'm done this is review sorry this
morning I went outside put Sims and left
go on and caught a bald eagle with my
bare hands and tamed it I had to train
them to peck the Italian supermodels who
throw themselves at me the instant they
see the Bleacher Report app before I put
my phone back on my sweat pant pocket
flapping in the breeze clinging to my
4-inch calves want to know why cuz
they're not American that's why every
morning I stare at my phone hoping for a
surprise episode
no luck I move on and print out a copy
of the Declaration of Independence and
consume it for sustenance before I hop
in my Ford f650 and drive to work which
is Walmart I manage a store because they
got one good look at this 100%
constitutional man of freedom and
collapsed to the floor weeping with
pride for the USA of America I was
instinctively instantly promoted and I
make 17 dollars and 76 cents per hour on
the weekends i reenact mascot battles
only there's always a new combatant
myself and I crane kick the wimpy non
Steelers mascot like the Communists I
imagine the heavy this is a 49er this is
a five-star podcast just as I am a
five-star man note I'm actually born and
raised in Canada before coming to the
u.s. for school and I'm coming to the
draft party not lacking it
self-confidence I like there's a
purebred American I like it it's the
Declaration of Independence for
sustenance of it and got a paid 1776 oh
yeah I think maybe we give have meet him
give a speech right before you fight
Manny Pacquiao out the draft party oh no
I use this as my that was the thing I
had with with Kerry Collins this is like
our thing that I always I would like I
was always I want to ask if you think
you're better than Kerry Collins no I'm
not I mean I can't say that I had the
ability to maybe be better than him but
I can't say that Kerry was good Kerry
was very good asked if you played in
that in that playoff would you have
beaten that Ravens do you know because I
was not a hundred percent healthy and he
played really good man Kerry
Kerry's Kerry was a really good NFL
quarterback if we got packing out the
draft party you'd get in the ring with
him like if we set up a boxing ring in
your data box I'm not talking about a
real fight oh you want to UFC say locker
room Brandon Stokley I believe it's told
the podcast my nickname was [ __ ] started
right because I was always a king of
walking in the locker and got LeBron is
better than Kobe you're like starting
that whole argument and I don't know how
it went but I just walked in one day in
Tennessee that if they were talking
about fighting us man
I'd kick the [ __ ] out of Manny Pacquiao
you know if you guys turn around like
dog dead serious
I would whoop many Pacquiao's ass yeah
and Kerry Collins is like shut your
mouth he would hit you so fast and I was
like you know then I just went on with
that I don't know he's 137 pounds I'm
232 pounds I mean if he doesn't catch me
with the quick one-two right off the bat
I mean if we get to the ground and my
hands are on him I'm winning I'm with in
that battle but I am scared of that papa
that's an undercard catch as you want
baby catch enjoy it's the chronic thing
when it's a smaller guy facing a bigger
guy it's like if he gets inside it's
over here like that's always right
like like Oh Tyson versus Lennox Lewis
if he gets inside it's over yes always
all right so that was a very long
podcast hope you guys enjoyed it for the
weekend no joke longest podcast ever and
I'm kidding you've said that at least 25
is it last year our and 45 minutes
longer our 55 thank you guys for joining
us you understand for five minutes and
do two hours do it let's make it happen
how many different versions of that
color do you own is just that's
unbelievable what he buys the shirt
so--but dot ly sim 70 the sim 70 shirt
is now available yeah if you buy it I'd
love to start setting those pictures if
you get it like I want to see you guys
wear and I'm gonna be really cool yeah
we have a few more shirts coming soon or
we have another one coming out next week
next week yep and it's I think it's a
really good one I saw today whoa big
offseason guys love you so much for Sims
peace out homey for federal evening
everybody and for the lef koe man we
appreciate you just be a human that
loves other humans and you'll be fine
Sims enough go Wow aren't you guys see
you soon